[Music] They're
so
cute
[Music]
I
like Tenmans when I see puppies. I think it's a really good encore song.
In fact,
the concept of the album changes as our emotions change,
so maybe we
'll give you a future pack that's the closest to that situation or something like that.  I
feel like we're the
first to debut
[Music] It's okay to
talk all the time, so I'm in a good mood
too.
I wish I could be someone's
role model
Wow I like it
[Music] It's
surprising how we
lived together, that's what I said when we first started the program.  You
didn't see it.
I didn't see it. The size of the building is a bit small. When we first
went up to the second floor, some food was
prepared, but there was
a lot of food, so it was
really nice.
[Music] To be honest, I thought it was
a bit like that, so I
wanted to walk there, but while
touring, it wasn't a lot, but I
did a little bit, but there are so many places I haven't been to yet.
I want to continue to do various concerts and meet my fans quickly. I
think it will be similar, but I
think the biggest motivation is to stage and perform in front of the fans and then receive cheers for it.  [
Music]
What day is today?
Monday
Then, since I'm a student now,
I think I'm studying.
Go for it, don't be picky
guys
[Music] I
watch it a lot.
Sometimes on TikTok, the engine people
put really cool music on it and they just edit it. It's
cool to see that.
[Music] He looks
like a sleigh, Shepherd, a
very long puppy. What was he doing?
[Laughs] [
Music] [
Music] It's
this concert.
It's a little stress relief. That's
right.
[Music]